Things to think about for your social
media page are making sure you follow
the guidelines for each platform.
Make sure you have all the things like
a cover photo, a profile photo, and
a description.
And make sure that you have a tone
of voice for your brand and
you're sticking to it.
You want your company
to have a voice and
a personality that's
recognizable by your customers.
Because you already know
your market segment or
your persona, you'll know how
to communicate with them.
Now, if it's relevant to your audience,
try to be a little bit light hearted and
delight your user in a funny way.
>> Make users smile from the way
you communicate with them.
>> MailChimp let's you have
a little bit of fun when you're
setting up your account.
If you try to choose a username
that already exists, they say,
maybe it's your evil twin, spooky.
You kind of get their personality
through that and it's delightful and
it will make you smile if you notice it.
Check out readme, when you're about
to put in your password the little
owl covers up his eyes,
it's a cute little extra touch.
Once you have your basic setup and your
unique tone of voice, all you have to do
is simply find the secret sauce
to make your content go viral.
Easy, right?
Well, no, it's actually the most
challenging thing with social media.
It's really hard to predict what
your audience will share, and
what they're really
going to engage with.
>> Hopefully, you'll measure everything
you do and be able to learn from it.
If your app is great,
users will spread the word for you.
You should make it easy for
users to share by adding
a social feature to your app.
Google recently launched app
invites which will allow your
users to easily share your
app with their contacts.
App invites will recommend your users
their closest contacts to share your app
with and give them an easy to download
link right in email or text message.
>> You see this a lot with game apps,
where your users are given an image to
share on Twitter with their highest
score or their ranking in the game.
You can also see this in
shopping apps when they
recommend that you post what
you just bought to Facebook.
>> Let's get an expert's
advice on social media.